what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel otherwise known
as whitest girl on earth uh speaking of
which i'm gonna turn this
down a little bit
okay today i am going to be reacting to
casey musgraves simple times
i have never heard this song before
and i heard that this album is like
super depressing so naturally i got
excited and i'm ready to watch
before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
all right
[Music]
every day felt like friday
me and all of my best friends
we were always together i remember
talking on the phone all night
didn't know it was a simple
[Music]
there's nothing wrong
[Music]
wow
i really that's clever this isn't
depressing
like i thought it was going to be about
a boy but
no this this kind of reminds me of like
going to the mall as a kid
except i was built a little different we
didn't like get dressed up
when i was a kid
my friends used to buy candy and dare me
to do things so they would
like i remember one time
should i say this on it i'm gonna do it
i talk too much anyway one time my
friend emily right she gave me candy to
put my face on the victoria's secret
glass like as if i was in awe of like
the victoria's secret model
but
i talk too much
[Music]
that's all you have to do is them the
bag
that was me with my friends too
it kind of looks like a boy to be honest
but i'm tall as hell that was me give
him back they're gonna like your
pigtails and they're gonna compliment
you and everything
oh hi big losers kidding you're not
really losers you're like sister you're
actually like sisters to me but um yeah
i uh i got i had the car for like 45
minutes because it's my nana's car and
she's a big [ __ ]
okay okay
i'm gonna i got the goods for you the
things that you need i'm not gonna say
what they are
back up back up no i'm kidding i'm
kidding one second it's just
so i spent all night just making those
hurry up but i got the goods that you
took out exactly what you wanted so and
maybe next time and then maybe next time
that i go with you
maybe next time i could go
with you
so next time i'll go with you sis know
your worth what are you doing but
watch the car totally catch you later
catch you later
thank you have fun i don't even want to
go too nervous
bye
oh
okay
you're welcome
me in high school
i think i'm going over the deep end i
want to wake up on an island
[Music]
we could stay up all night
[Music]
there's nothing wrong i need to step
away
and if i don't want to go insane cause
being grown up kind of sucks and i'm
really just
[Music]
okay if they're doing something like
robbing or whatever this is the most
inefficient
like fighting robbing whatever whatever
they're doing costume ever
like
what is with the knee pads like what is
that
[Music]
is
yes
[Music]
oh my god
i hope that's never me
like i want to get married and stuff but
oh my god i hope that's never me just
like
oh my god they're so annoying
you brought
swords these are the dumbest criminals
i've ever seen in my life and the heels
[Music]
cause
times
[Music]
i'm so confused as to what this has to
do with the song we're robbing
a dress
a dress store i think
or a wedding store
maybe the theme is like
don't get married i don't know men are
terrible
um
i mean i can't the production value of
that song was good but like
i just don't even know how to feel um
let me know in the comments if you guys
liked it i feel weird i give it like a
two out of five not my favorite
um don't forget to subscribe
like
alright bye guys